all right so first of all let's get the
sunscreen first of all I just want to
say I'm a little bit embarrassed about
my outfit that I'm not as handsome as
Florida over here or Vanessa in the
other room the truth is I brought a
really nice stylish shirt to wear today
but my hotel room didn't have an iron I
called him at seven in the morning and
they took way too long to bring it up so
I just thought like you know I was
actually panicking this morning called
my boyfriend and I was like I don't have
anything else to wear just the trekking
gear for this weekend and like maybe
I'll just go onstage and look like a
mountaineer so he was like it's okay
it's a Developer Conference and I was
like that's right I'm gonna just be
myself and be comfortable and be really
cozy like a mountaineer talking about
augmented reality so let me just
introduce myself my name is race' and
I'm a creative engineer at Google my
team one day was looking for ways to use
augmented reality in one of our
marketing campaigns so I took the
liberty of just doing the research on my
own seeing what's possible and naturally
I just started digging out into the
history got really excited about the
many many years that it has gone back
and wanted to share with my team to help
them appreciate what it is today and of
course do my actual job of reporting
back what's possible today and in the
future so what is possible in the future
actually and before I start I want to
just make a really quick disclaimer that
I'm all this research all this research
I did was on my own it's all public
knowledge and with that being said I'm
speaking on behalf of myself and not on
behalf of my company or any of the
organizations I'm a part of so let's
step back into history all the way back
into 1901 this was a time before
airplanes before traditional color
photography that we know and nearly a
decade before the world's the first
talking motion picture yet before all of
these technological advancements we had
a visionary author called L frank Baum
who you see up here and he envisioned a
world in a novel that he wrote called
master key he wrote about a world where
one could put on a pair of spectacles
and the people that he would look at it
would overlay a character over their
head and this this device was called a
character marker so basically he's
looking around and can judge a person on
a single look so this was these were
some really deep sci-fi thoughts back in
1901 such like I can't even imagine how
he could have came up with this idea and
if the name rings a bell he's author of
The Wizard of Oz so maybe it's not so
surprising after all then fast forward
to 1968 we a lot has happened in this
time America has built the first 747
we've orbited the moon from Apollo 8 and
at the same time we have the world's
first head mounted display this was
developed by of Harvard professor called
Ivan Sutherland and this display that
you see here it was so heavy it has to
be mounted from the ceiling and there's
this funny video on YouTube where you
can see him like spinning around and all
he's seeing is this really simple wire
cube so after all this hard work you saw
this visionary cube in space and this
was a really important precursor to a
art because as you'll see there's been
so many advancements with head mounted
displays these days and now looking at
2018 we have the rocket orbiting into
space with the car that's now somewhere
out there floating but at the same time
we also have all of these advancements
in augmented reality everyone is talking
about when it's going to be the next big
thing for the past few years
technologists and investors alike or
speculating on when this is going to
really blow up so what is happening
after all of these years you see that
there's rich history of over a century
ago that dates back on mentioned reality
since at least 1901 so if you look at
this chart from Google Trends in case
you haven't used it before the y-axis is
the search interest from 0 to 100 and on
the x-axis we have time so I'm I did a
search back until the past two and a
half years to see how interested people
were in augmented reality and as you can
see there's some interesting activity
going on here
suddenly in the summer of 2016 we see a
huge peak and people are curious about
this mysterious AR thing that they've
just sort of and this is when Pokemon go
is released so all of a sudden we have
people using this cool new app and
wondering like whoa what is augmented
reality and I want what else is possible
with this thing this opened up this was
probably the most popular AR application
although as we'll see it's not fully AR
capable and they're working on that
application fully AR pokemon go soon but
this really opened people consumers eyes
into the possibilities of AR and really
showed the potential for its scale then
later in more recent years around the
fall of 2017 we have another peak that's
starting to rise and although it's not
as high as pokemon go this was from AR
core and era kit which were announced
roughly around the same time and these
are developer kits that will allow
people to build experiences such as
Pokemon go and much easier and much more
streamlined way so it's a quick
definition air core is a platform for
building augmented reality apps on
Android and AR kit is Apple's version
for building AR apps on iOS looking back
a few more years this is as far back as
you can go on Google Trends from 2004
you see that there's actually some
activity going on people are actually
interested and aware of augmented
reality especially around 2009 so that
was almost 10 years ago and why does it
seem like it's such a new thing now this
is when AR tool kit was released for web
it's an open-source toolkit I guess if
you want to compare it to AR core and AR
kit this allowed developers to build
web-based applications so this was
actually the output would be flash based
so this is one of the reasons why it
didn't really take on because users have
to install a plug-in and then they kind
of have to like use their webcam in a
weird way that it doesn't feel natural
compared to a mobile device
where you can take it around with you
and it makes more sense to like kind of
point at what you want to project your
AR object onto so this really shows it
state the documentation of AR toolkit or
this publication about it describes what
AR toolkit is it shows a our toolkit in
action and as you can see it's marker
based so they have this code where it
will project the the object from the
code and then in the documentation you
can also see that it's using Windows XP
and telling you how to use a webcam on
your computer then later in 2009 we have
the introduction of augmented reality
into the real world so Esquire post
Esquire published this issue it was an
augmented reality special and on the
front cover you had this QR code that
you could scan and then something
magical happens Robert Downey Downey jr.
comes out of the screen and starts like
acknowledging you and then there was
also as you saw in the previous screen
there's there were 12 pages of a our
content and lots of publications we're
talking about it and it was really
becoming more noticeable to consumers so
fast forwarding to today we have back in
2012 Google Hangouts filters which is
actually long before snapchat which many
people don't know snapchats world lenses
we have a huge advancement of
head-mounted displays like the microsoft
hololens and then of course pokemon goes
very well known and the IKEA went of
Ikea like he is a furniture app from
Apple's Apple Store so what's making
this possible today is that we have much
more powerful devices much more powerful
browsers that will hopefully soon be
capable of a our developers are more
well equipped with toolkits like AR core
and air kit and hopefully future support
on the web will help to bring this
technology to the masses so let's go
back to basis and basics and talk about
what defines augmented reality apps
so air Corrigan is the software
developer kit that allows developers to
use these defining air features in AR in
Android applications and these defining
features include motion tracking which
allows the device to understand and
track its position relative to the real
world so a scare coat you can place into
the world and move around and it looks
like it's stationary just like these
people next to it and environmental
understanding so that the device can
detect the size and location of
previously it was only horizontal
surfaces but now with the release of AR
core 1.0 you can also place it on
textured surfaces and there was this
cool demo of placing things on the snow
like around the tree it's pretty cool
and then lighten estimation which allows
the device to estimate the lighting
conditions and this really helps bring
objects to life because even the
subtleties like shadows and brightness
can really make an object in in the real
world look real so previously we have we
had a platformer called tango which
allowed augmented reality on these
really powerful devices but as these
were very specialized we decided we
wanted to bring this to the masses and
that's when we really focus our efforts
from late last year on a our core which
will make it make augmented reality
possible on more Android devices so that
is a huge challenge but also a really
big opportunity the fact that there are
two billion plus active devices out
there running on Android and each of
these has their own unique hardware
requirements and hardware specs that we
have to make sure align and provide the
same high quality experience that we
want all users to have so currently with
the most recent release it works on 100
million devices which includes 13 unique
models that you see here and we're
working with partners to make sure that
more devices can support this and going
back to AR kits this is a software
developer kit allowing developers to use
the same essential features in iOS 11
the way to describe it it's it's very
similar to the three basic
features that that Eric or suggest those
are basically essential AR features not
AR core like there there's they can be
described for any element to the reality
out and their device compatibility is
all most recent Apple devices so with a
nine plus a nine chip we're above
running iOS 11 and up so that includes
iPhone 6s setup and some of the newer
iPads so let's talk about building for
web because all of this air core and air
kit allows you to build native apps but
this is a j/s conference so you guys are
probably bored thinking about building
an F we want to build for web so let's
see what's possible air core currently
has an experiment where they're
exploring the possibilities of web
support which would be awesome because
it will lower the barrier to entry and
people can build apps and release them
to out to the web so this is like a pre
standards experimentation just trying to
see what's explore what's possible and
it's basically a wrapper of chromium and
it's extending web VR features so that
it's really scalable and allows for
fallbacks and across multiple devices so
they have this cool demo called article
which you can download on github
just npm install all the dependencies
and run it on the web pack server and
it's super easy and just to explain air
core for web is not one single entity
it's basically you're building a web app
with a our capabilities you're using JSI
Ares to build the 3d objects and then
you are running it on this experimental
browser that's supposed to emulate what
the web standards might look like and
currently they have experimental
browsers that work on both Android and
iOS so they're called err where they are
on air core and web a are on air kit
respectively and most of the examples on
the web a are for air core demos are
built with three Jas it's a really
popular 3d modeling library that's been
used since 2010
some of Google's projects have used it
including the poly library this
educational experience experience called
inter land and all of these other cool
Google and on Google experiments that
you see here and it allows you to create
3d shapes animations complex scenes and
gives you some tools to make this a lot
easier for you because as you'll find 3d
modeling concepts are really hard so
this is one of the tools that it
provides it's an in-browser kind of
shape editor or scene editor and it
allows you to control all these
different parameters and it's a really
good way to kind of start learning 3d
modeling and especially if you haven't
been paying attention in math class like
I did you have to relearn kind of UV
mapping and vectors and matrix
multiplication and it really sometimes
it's a little bit overwhelming but with
tools like this it becomes a lot easier
and if you get good you can make some
crazy 3d shapes like this but if you are
having trouble with 3d modeling you can
also download some models on poly and
find all these different kinds of
cheeseburgers anything like just
basically search for the term and you'll
find different items that are tagged
with that description and if you really
like these cheeseburgers you can just
put it all together start throwing them
in the air
and then that's your AR app so just to
just to highlight what's possible with
three days this is one of the apps that
my team has built called Qibla finder
and it helps people find the direction
of Qibla which is the direction of
prayer during Ramadan and basically we
use three J s but they are core and AIRC
it were not yet available and this was
also a web app so we kind of had to get
creative and this is basically just
using WebRTC to use the camera and
navigation api's and basically it's
projecting this into space rather than
as we've learned as an essential AR
feature it doesn't allow you to kind of
place it onto a detected surface so it's
it's a kind of like faux AR but it
um I guess you can compare it to
pokemons go where you're not really
placing the you're not really throwing
the pokeball onto the the Pokemon that's
it's not on the floor it's kind of just
like sometimes it's floating around so
that's kind of one distinction of what's
possible with three J s and how we need
to bridge the gap so to bridge those
gaps there is a library called three rjs
which kind of detects the device
compatibility and enables the AR Web
utilities by interfacing with the web VR
extension that is exposed by the
experimental browsers so that's what's
allowing you to throw things onto
surfaces and detect it with precision so
putting it all together you can create
some really useful apps like for example
this living room modeling there's some
really useful things you can do for
consumers to make this really widely
adopted and especially if it's available
for the web then people can just reach
these experiment experiences from a link
and access them if their device is
compatible so again the web AR on-air
core implementation is just an
exploration right now to explore what's
possible and what might be potential web
standards but there are also a lot more
web implementations for example Mozilla
has their web X our standards proposal
which there's a lot of commonalities
between the different pre standards
proposals right now so that's a good
sign that things are starting to align
and hopefully we have some standards
soon there's also the Argonne browser
and Argonne jeaious and I think one of
the most popular ones might be the
marker based a rjs and if you recognize
the markers from my earlier slides it's
because it's based on a our tool kit so
it goes way back so with all of these
standards that are not really fully in
place why should we care about it now
like what if it changes and stressing
you guys out to learn all these new
things but as you know with 3d modeling
it's it's a really big concept to grasp
and if you start learning it now like
there's a lot to catch up on people are
already using 3GS and have been 3d
modeling for decades so it's really good
if you're interested in it now and
you should start equipping yourself with
the basic knowledge to get started and
people are already building really cool
stuff right now
so some sources of inspiration there's
some AR core specific examples on this
is AR core calm there's also an AR kit
version at the bottom there and one of
my personal favorites is this one from
Jericho / AR experiments which just
features some of Google's I mean not
biased or anything but some of Google's
AR experiments but one of the reasons
why I love it so much is that half of
the experiments on there were created by
women so that's really awesome to show
that representation in the web XR
community and going back to Ivan
Sutherland the Harvard professor who
created the first headband to display
he said that the screen is a window
through which one sees a virtual world
and the challenge is to make that world
look real act real sound real and feel
real so with all these technological
advancements in the past century or so I
think we're we're getting really close
to that and although we might not be
close to these know really complex head
not to displays I can control an armored
suit or anything I think it's really
exciting that we can we're getting
really close to building web-based AR
applications because that's is what's
really gonna make AR become more
widespread so thank you guys for
listening
you